digamos que la acción x de z tiene un
precio del comercio de 31 pesos se tiene
una opción de compra con un precio de
ejercicio de 35 pesos y se cotiza en 8
pesos también tenemos una opción de
venta con un precio de ejercicio de 35
pesos y ésta se cotiza en 12 pesos y ojo
tienen la misma fecha de vencimiento
finalmente tenemos un bono y este bono
no tiene que ver con la acción x jeter
pues es un bono libre de riesgo no se
pueden ser letras de un tesoro o lo que
sea y este tiene un valor de 35 pesos
con opción de expiración y lo puedes
comprar justo ahora por la cantidad de
30 pesos es decir la forma de ver esto
es que tú pagas justo ahorita 30 pesos y
vas a obtener 35 pesos en un futuro con
opción de expiración que esencialmente
te va a dar interés sobre este bono y
bueno ya sabiendo todos estos datos
habrá forma de hacer dinero que esté
libre de riesgo para resolver esta duda
pensemos un poco en la famosa paridad de
la compraventa es decir hemos aprendido
que la acción más la venta y me refiero
a la venta en el precio de ejercicio
esto es igual y ojo hay que tener la
misma fecha de vencimiento
a la compra de esa acción compra en el
precio de ejercicio la compra de esta
subyacente acción más el bono libre de
riesgo que tendrá en el precio de
ejercicio en el momento de expiración de
estas opciones ahora bien como esta es
una igualdad entonces esta cantidad o
este pago debe ser igual en cualquier
circunstancia en la fecha de vencimiento
entonces vamos a sustituir y que tenemos
primeramente la acción x y z tiene un
precio de comercio de 31 pesos por lo
tanto vamos a sustituir la app por 31
más ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasaba con la venta de la acción que
nosotros teníamos que ésta se cotizaba
en 12 pesos por lo tanto hay que
aumentarle 12 pesos y eso tiene que ser
igual a 31 más 12 que es 43 bueno esto
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación ahora
qué pasa del lado izquierdo de la
igualdad tenemos que la compra se
cotizaba en 8 pesos
ya estoy comentarle el precio del bono
que era de 30 pesos por lo tanto 8 más
30 nos dan 38 y que creen aquí hay una
diferencia enorme tenemos del lado
izquierdo 43 pesos del lado derecho a 38
pesos y así
y vemos que no tienen el mismo pago en
la fecha de vencimiento y es que miden
la compra más el bono es más barato que
la acción más la venta y qué va a pasar
en este caso pues en este caso es cuando
tú tienes una gran oportunidad de
obtener una ganancia de esta
irregularidad en el precio de estas dos
cosas y es que esencialmente estos dos
valores deben de ser iguales por eso en
esta ocasión lo que debes hacer es
comprar la parte más barata y después
vender a la parte más cara especialmente
cuando es la misma igualdad es decir
cuando tendrán el mismo pago en un
futuro entonces lo que tienes que hacer
es una venta corte de estación que
esencialmente no es más que vender tu
acción o dicho de otra manera vas a
tener una venta corta de tu opción de
venta o digámoslo así tú puedes escribir
una opción de venta es decir la venta
corta más escribir la venta vamos a
escribirlo una vez lo que tenemos que
hacer es la venta corta más escribir la
venta es decir escribir una opción de
venta entonces vamos a obtener 31 pesos
de la venta corta de la acción y
escribir la venta no significa más que
crear una opción de venta y venderla a
alguien más
entonces vamos a obtener 12 pesos de
ello es decir vamos a obtener en total
31 pesos más 12 pesos de la mente de
acción lo que me da en total 43 pesos y
ya con esto comprarás el bono y la
opción de compra así que te gastarás 8
pesos en la compra más 30 pesos en el
bono es decir 38 pesos y si hacemos la
diferencia nos van a quedar 5 pesos de
ganancia lo que vamos a ver en el
siguiente vídeo es que tu ganancia
aumente o el sudado caso que se conserve
sin importar lo que le pasa el precio de
la acción así podrás organizar tus
operaciones y quedarte con tus 5 pesos
de ganancia